hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
trailer for the new Tom Cruise flick
called edge of tomorrow I love Tom
Cruise I'm just hoping he runs in this
film that perfect posture he has [ __ ]
love Tom Cruise this has been approved
for appropriate audiences I am about to
tell you sounds crazy Libyan part 2 but
you have to listen to me your very lives
depend on it yes he's in Texas
[Music]
you see this isn't the first time
oh [ __ ] and we've had this conversation
what tasted Judgment Day you just came
in with the fresh recruits mister mrs.
Smith the invasion will fail long as
every soldier you are sending we lose
everything
Oh some find me when you wake up
[Music]
you do know what's happening to me what
happened to you happened to me oh it's
like Elysium
religion is what exactly winning the war
we can do this
just come here every day and I'll train
you
just like wait so much like a living
digging the music alright Oh spike and
zilhajja come
matter what happens to me
[Music]
we've got a motorcycle again
I'm not a soldier of course you know
you're a weapon yeah [ __ ] that looks
awesome
hi max [ __ ] that movie looks [ __ ]
cool I love Tom Cruise man he's intense
I'd smoke a blunt with Emily Blunt oh I
can't believe I'm the first one to come
up with that joke